so nice to get to meet you and chat with
you congratulations on the new single
open door with your band knights in
stereo it is fantastic but before we
talk about the track i want to know how
did this band come together
well first of all thank you very much
thanks for having me man this is amazing
to be able to promote the show i'm
see i'm used to talking about the show
to be able to promote the song on uh et
canada so thank you
um you know my my um my best friend in
the whole world johnny who's in the band
um
in 2020 uh
like around summer time when everybody
was locked down
um we were very deprived for
you know for
from a creative standpoint
and um i came over one day and he was
messing around with music and
i heard a track and i was like hey
do you think maybe i could
maybe do some vocals on it and uh he's
like yeah sure and we started doing that
and then after a couple sessions it
actually started to sound pretty good
and things started to come
together pretty pretty nicely
and uh
we gave it a listen
we we gave the song a listen to our dear
friend who's our producer mike riley
and um he's been doing this forever and
works with everybody and
when he was like this is actually really
good we should work on this seriously
um that was sort of the boost of
confidence that we needed and um also
like you know reassurance that we're not
you know delusional um
so we we got into the studio into a very
beautiful
um expensive studio
and uh
we made the song open door and um
it was the first song that we sort of
all felt like it was the song that we
wanted to put out into the world first
and it was the one that
was created uh organically and and the
most ideas were flowing
um and we locked it in like two weeks
ago
and now
probably by the time this is out the
song will be out for the entire world
it is fantastic it has this vibe to it
that almost gives me a bit of nostalgia
of like the best years of my life like
cruising down niagara falls it just has
that vibe to it so was there a common
thread that you and the rest of the band
really wanted to achieve with your sound
it's interesting because my
my bandmates rodrigo and johnny their
their influences are
so different than mine you know like
johnny our lead guitarist and sort of
the musical genius behind all this like
he listens from
metallica to slayer to casey musgraves
to
you know pretty much everything and and
my big influence is kings of leon
especially
vocals um so
i think us combining all of those sort
of inspirations
um turned into this thing now
called open door and i think the one
thing that we all
share is that we love music that makes
us feel good
and um and we could really jam out too
because
you know i feel like open door is a song
that you play in the car
full blast
and
you can just head bang and have a good
time and
um it's also a song that you can listen
to multiple times and i think i think
you get a different feeling each time
and and there's sort of like a
sense of discovery with the song so
we're we're really really proud of it
yeah you mentioned kings of leon there
and that is exactly the vibe that i got
so growing up who were some of your
musical influences obviously kings of
leon is a huge one you mentioned casey
musgraves there but right now who are
you listening to that you're like damn
they're putting out some real good music
so for me i'm sort of like uh
i'm sort of old school man i i love to
listen what what i know and what i love
um
i i still very much listen to nirvana on
a daily basis i listen to
red hot chili peppers on a daily basis i
still
have the new king's leon album on repeat
um but then you know with with us now
being in a band i'm always getting new
music sent to me by johnny and he's like
you need to listen to this group and
this group and it's always he he has
showed me so much mute like he's the one
that showed me war on drugs
war paint casey musgraves
um real estate so you know we have a
very wide variety of musical um sort of
knowledge now and it's uh we're just
gonna keep sort of i think pulling
inspiration from as much music as we can
is the idea to take this on the road
eventually are you hoping to tour i mean
the world of course is a difficult place
to do that right now but down the line
is that something you're hoping to do
that's a huge goal of ours it's um
i i know for me and i could probably
speak for the rest of us that um going
to concerts is our
most um
i think it's our it's our biggest love
when it comes to entertainment and we
know what it's like to be in the crowd
i can't even imagine what it's like to
be on stage
with you know
10 to 20 000 people singing your song it
must be the greatest feeling in the
whole world
um so that's definitely very very high
on our bucket list and you know
hopefully people love this song and we
can get back into the studio and we have
a bunch of other songs that um are like
halfway finished so there's a lot of
work for us to to still be doing and um
we'll see what the reaction is
well i hope you will hit the road uh
thinking of a concert concerts like you
said are one of my favorite things to
attend i think my favorite concert if i
can tell you ever was lady gaga's art
rave for oh my god for album art pop it
was insane what is the best concert that
you've ever seen
madison square garden kings of leon
i believe it was 2016.
um
i've never rocked out so hard in my life
and i was standing
like five feet away from the stage and
it was
i i still get goosebumps when i think
about certain songs um and and the cool
thing about concerts and i'm sure you
could relate to this is that you can
never hear the song the same way when
you listen to it like on your headphones
or something because you have that
experience with it live and a lot of
times great bands will make certain
songs um unique to the live experience
which i know king's leon do a lot
um so yeah
you can't you can't top madison square
garden
that's pretty epic another epic thing is
9-1-1 lone star what an incredible show
congratulations on being part of it
because it has found such an audience tk
has become a fan favorite on the show uh
what is playing tk meant to you
it's still like
sort of mind-blowing um you know three
seasons later uh
especially because the
the fan base just keeps growing and it
seems to be reaching more parts of the
world that i don't think any of us could
have ever imagined like
we have fan bases ranging from slovakia
to
you know to um
i've been speaking to people from egypt
all the way to you know california and
new york and it's um it's just
unbelievable to see how wide a variety
of audience this show could touch
and um i think the most important thing
is the stories that we're telling yeah
um on on a network show
which is rare to see these kind of
characters
and these stories on a network show
especially on fox
are absolutely right yeah
so i think it's um
it's just unbelievable man and it's
every single day i hear from somebody
new
um you know reaching out and telling us
what the show means to them and what tk
means to them and
what the what the real life actors mean
to them and it's every single day it's
it's truly changing people's lives and
on such a deeper level than just being
you know a character on a tv show it's
it's really really really unbelievable
yeah listen i'm just going to tell you
the truth like as a queer person myself
i didn't grow up seeing this kind of
stuff on mainstream media so to have a
character like tk in a same-sex
relationship i can only imagine the
amount of messages that you get from
people saying you know i feel seen and
thank you for this like is there a
message that stands out in your mind
that you received where you're just like
wow this really is changing lives
i think the biggest one that i could
sort of think of from the
it always stands out is i sort of call
him my real-life tk
he's a he's a queer firefighter from
canada
um
he
um was very much closeted did not feel
safe and comfortable telling his peers
um
we were talking for most of season one
and season two
um and then he saw that tk became a
paramedic and it inspired him to become
a paramedic so now
he moved from a rural town in canada to
vancouver where now he's fully himself
he's out to his um to his firehouse and
he uh he even got um a saying that i
wrote down tattooed on his arm which is
so we have a very
very personal beautiful connection and i
i always joke with him i call him my
real life tk and he's um he's so happy
now and he's a paramedic and now he's on
the verge of going to medical school and
wants to become a doctor so this is all
because of the show and it's like it's i
i
i can't believe it you know it's really
it's really crazy
yeah and because of the show too i read
that you were actually inspired to come
out yourself as bisexual and you know i
hate saying congratulations because i
feel like i shouldn't have to in this
day and age but
it must have felt like a huge weight off
of your own shoulders to just kind of
share that with people and share that
honesty and the support that you
received from coming out as bisexual
that too must have been incredibly
powerful to you knowing that you doing
that
really has probably inspired thousands
of other people because again that's not
something we see in mainstream media we
don't see hollywood stars
spreading by
spreading by visibility you know so what
has that reaction been like for you and
how has it felt to just put that out
into the world and live your true honest
life
it's 100 true um
it was a massive weight off my shoulders
more in the sense of
i i could be
transparent with my close family and
friends and that to be completely honest
was not easy um i almost
knew that the i guess the masses or or
the fans would be way more
um supportive and loving than maybe
certain people in my life
you know certain people in my life are
not there anymore because of this and
certain people in my life i think our
relationship has gotten stronger and
i've actually learned um
incredible things about people that i i
was
really nervous about and i thought that
i was going to lose those certain people
and they actually became the most the
most supportive and the most loving
and then you know in the sense of sort
of the masses and and and the fan base
they have been
the greatest part about all this i i
literally have a hashtag for them i call
them the best fans in the world because
they are so much more than fans you know
they they sort of are like family at
this point because we've been through so
much especially
with the show with the pandemic with me
coming out
um
and it's been a it's been such an
incredible journey and i still to this
day
get messages from people all over the
world all different ages
um
explaining to me what my story has meant
to them and and how i inspire them and a
lot of them are now coming out to their
family and friends or just
really taking the first step of being
comfortable with themselves
and not necessarily telling everybody
but i think the first step of you being
comfortable with yourself is i think a
massive step and i think i i think the
rest will follow so
um it's it's been
unbelievable and um
literally almost every single day um
somebody's reaching out and it's uh
it's it's it's truly incredible i it's
really hard to put into words it's um
it's really something
yeah it's it is truly incredible and
like i said i wish that you know
hollywood had more people like yourself
i know they're out there just sharing
you know who they are and that's not to
force anybody into doing it if they're
not ready you know everybody like you
said you have to accept yourself first
and foremost um but just you sharing
that message is incredibly incredibly
powerful so thank you for that thank you
the band is awesome congratulations
congratulations on the show big things
all good things for you i can't wait to
hear more and uh hopefully see a show in
person maybe in toronto sometime soon oh
my god yeah absolutely vancouver
montreal and calgary i love all those
cities so yes
i will be there if it comes
congratulations again thank you so much
for chatting thank you for having me
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos